[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन
कल
तब तक 1 मिनट वेट करते हैं बाकी लोगों को
आने का उसके बाद स्टार्ट करते हैं
[संगीत]
वेरी गुड
उसे किया है जो आपने आउटपुट प्रोवाइड किया
है जो मेरे को कमांड जो मुझे चाहिए होती
वो आपने सही कमांड दिया है जो मुझे
एक्सपेक्टेशन था होमवर्क था वेरी गुड
छोड़ी थी की वहां पर हमने जब लास्ट में
फाइंड और रिप्लेस वाला जो टॉपिक था ना
वहां पर हमने अपनी
सीडी कमांड को छोड़ था तो कंटिन्यू करते
हैं एलसीडी कमांड जो हमारी बच्ची हुई है
उसके बाद जो नेक्स्ट कमांड होगी वो ग्राफ
कमांड होगी और अगर हमारा टाइम हो तो हम कट
कमांड के बड़े में सीखने वाले हैं वैलिड
डीटेल्स
जो हमेशा कम करते आए हैं तो अभी भी करेंगे
तो स्टार्ट करते हैं की जो सीडी सरिता
एडिटर जो कमांड है उसमें हम कैसे परफॉर्म
करते हैं किसी भी डिलीट ऑपरेशन डिलीट
ऑपरेशन कैसे परफॉर्म करेंगे मैं बताता हूं
आपको सिंपली आपको क्या करना है अभी मैं एक
बार देख लेट हूं की मेरे को फाइल कहां पर
है जहां पर मैंने अपने पेशेंट ओके अगर मैं
करता हूं
टक्स डाउनलोड
समय तक मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं डिलीट
करना चाहता हूं अपनी लाइंस को तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा उसके लिए कमेंट होती है से सिंपली
कैट है फ्रेंड
उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है वन फाइव वन तू
से लेकर 15
कहां तक करना मुझे वन फाइव
वन फाइव
तक मुझे करना है तो हम ऐसे करेंगे
सिंपली इंटर कर देंगे एडरवाइज दूसरा जो
इसका सिंटेक्स है वो भी हम उसे कर सकते
हैं की सेल कमांड उसे करेंगे इसके बाद
क्या करेंगे जो कैट हिफिन एम देने की बजे
हम क्या करेंगे वो फाइल का नाम इसके साथ
ही दे सकते हैं दो तरीके से आपको पता है
कैसे कर सकते हैं थोड़ा सा परफॉर्म अब
देखो
1512 से लेकर 15 तक हमारी लाइन नंबर क्या
होगी इसने डिलीट कर दिया अब मैं अगर आपको
दिखाऊं एक फाइल मैं पहले क्या करता हूं
क्या कर लेट हूं से कर लेट हूं अगर एलएस
करता हूं सैंपल डॉट
करता हूं
sample.ext
चैंप्स ओके ओके
सिंबल उसके बाद में क्या करने वाला हूं
सिंगल को उसके बाद हम उसे करने वाले हैं
लाइव नंबर 12 और उसके बाद हम ये उसे
करेंगे ये एस कलेशन मार्क इसका मतलब क्या
है की नोट इसको 12th लाइन है 12th नंबर जो
लाइन है जो लाइन है उसको छोड़ के सारे
लाइनें को क्या कर देना है डिलीट कर देना
है सिंपली दी ऑप्शन उसे करेंगे इसके साथ
में और हिट इंटर कर देंगे
अब देखो
इसमें क्या कर दिया डिलीट कर दिया
लेकिन क्या है की आपको पता है की यहां पर
दो टाइप का ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करता है कौन
स्क्रीन होता है और एक में फाइल में बट
अभी तक आपने
ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं कैसे कम करेंगे
हमारी कमांड जिसके साथ हम ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म
करना चाहते हैं तो हमने करके देखा है अगर
मुझे में फाइल के अंदर ये साड़ी चीज करनी
है डिलीट ऑपरेशन का परफॉर्म करना है तो
सिंपली हिफिन है का इसके साथ मैं उसे कर
सकता हूं अब जैसे की मुझे क्या करना है ये
तो हमारा डिलीट ऑपरेशन कैसे परफॉर्म कर
सकते हैं हम सरिता एडिटर कमांड के साथ अब
मैं इसमें नेक्स्ट इसके अंदर बताने वाला
हूं की किसी भी एक लाइन नंबर से पहले आप
अपने टेक्स्ट को इंसर्ट कैसे कर सकते हैं
उसके लिए सिंपली जैसे कैट करता हूं मैं
सैंपल रोड
टैक्सी है अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं की लाइन
नंबर 57 से ऊपर मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
इससे पहले एक लाइन इंसर्ट करना चाहता हूं
वह कौन सी लैंग्वेज करना चाहता हूं पर वो
कैसे करूंगा सिंपली सेट उसके बाद हिफिन
सॉरी
हेलो
आई एम
प्रैक्टिशनर
सिंपली फाइल का नाम सैंपल
उसके बाद क्या करना है
सिंपली अब देखिए
ये रहा 57 क्योंकि वो ऑन स्क्रीन कम कर
रहा है
तो देखो यहां पर हेलो वर्ल्ड एड हो गया और
इससे ऊपर था जो लाइन नंबर 57 से लास्ट में
हमने इंसर्ट करके दिखाए था तो आपने देखा
था तो सर क्या की ये सर का सर कम क्या कर
रहा है ऑन स्क्रीन हो रहा है अगर में फाइल
के अंदर में इंस्टेंट करना था तो कैसे
करूंगा
टेक्स्ट करके दिखता हूं अभी आपको 58 पर
हेलो वर्ल्ड एड हो जाएगा परमानेंटली में
फाइल के अंदर चेंज हो गया तो यह था हमारा
सेट कमांड के बड़े में सरिता एडिटर कमांड
के बड़े में वेरी डिटेल एक्सप्लेन
क्या-क्या इसके अंदर
चेक नहीं होगा
ओके
एक लॉगिन फाइल हमारे पास मतलब क्या है एक
है लोग की फाइल है लोग की फाइल है अब लोग
फाइल क्या होती है आपको सबको पता होगा
लाइनस के ऊपर या आप एक साइबो सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर हो आप सो कैनल स्टोर या आपके
कंटिन्यू लोग मॉनिटरिंग ड्यूटी कर रहे हो
अब होता क्या है की जब आप लोग मॉनिटरिंग
कर रहे थे तो किसी अटैक करने आपकी मशीन को
हिट करने की कोशिश की एवं विद उसका कोई
यूजर नाम आया हो या आपकी स्क्रीन पर उसका
आईपी एड्रेस आया हूं तो अब आपने क्या किया
उसको आप पहचान से वो आपकी नजर में ए गया
की हां कुछ तो हुआ है कुछ नोमाइलोस है की
नॉर्मल से अलग कुछ हुआ है की जो डेली
बेसिस पे होता है उसके अलावा कुछ होता है
उसको बोलते हैं
उसको आईडेंटिफाई किया की आपने उसको जब हिट
कर रहा था तो आपने क्या किया है उसका आईपी
एड्रेस नोट कर लिया या उसकी जिसका नाम रख
लिया नाम एड कर लिया और उसके ऊपर आपने
क्या किया जो भी किया है उसके बाद आपने
क्या किया उसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्ट
किया और उसे यूजर को बताने की कोशिश की अब
यूजर क्या बोल रहा है की मैंने तो नहीं
किया वो माना कर रहा है
बट अब सो की जो लोग फाइल है उसमें उसकी
एंट्री मिलेगी
पर एग्जांपल
करोगे उसके अंदर सर्चिंग करना बहुत ही
मुश्किल टास्क है ऐसे अगर मैन्युअल सर्च
करने बैठोगे तो आपको घंटा ग जाएंगे तब भी
उसे चीज को नहीं सर्च कर पाओगे क्योंकि हर
बार लोग फाइल क्या होती है अपडेट होते
रहती है हर सेकंड में और मेरी सेकंड में
अब इस चीज को करने के लिए मैन्युअल करने
की बजे हम उसे कम को कम करने के लिए
मैन्युअल वाले को हम उसे करते हैं
उसमें हम क्या करते हैं एक पैटर्न दे देते
हैं हमें पता है की जब हिट किया होगा तो
पैटर्न आया होगा की उसका योजना
कहां-कहां किस-किस लाइन के अंदर आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है जिससे आपका कम बहुत
ही आसन हो जाए और आप आईडेंटिफाई कर पाओगे
देखो यह मिल लॉगिन फाइल है आपने जब सर्वर
के साथ अटैक करने की कोशिश की थी मैं सरवन
ने लॉक कर लिया है और आप माना कर रहे थे
अब यह देखिए कितनी जगह पर इतनी इस लाइन
में इस लाइन नंबर के ऊपर आपने आपका लोग
हमारे पास क्या ए गया एंट्री कर गया है अब
वो झूठ नहीं बोल सकता तो ये सब चीज करने
के लिए कहना की अब सर कम लाइनस का राहत है
क्योंकि पूरा टोटली आप चाहे एथिकल हैकिंग
करो साइबर सिक्योरिटी करो कुछ भी करो या
लाइनेक्स एडमिन बना या किसी कंपनी में कम
करो सबसे ज्यादा लाइन उसे होता है में
सर्वर लाइनेक्स के ही होते हैं और अटैकिंग
का परफॉर्म करने के लिए भी उसे किया जाता
है और अगर और तास करने के लिए तो हर चीज
में लिरिक्स है
अपने कम आसन करने के लिए हम क्या है
अलग-अलग कमांड्स का उसे करते हैं
सारे कम प्रिंटिंग के कम इतनी आसानी से कर
देती यही पर अगर आप कैट कमांड करते थे उसे
करते थे उसके बाद उसमें सर्च करते थे ली
कमांड उसे करते थे फिर उसमें सर्च करते थे
मोर कमांड उसे करते थे हेड कमांड बोल ऊपर
से नीचे ओनली आ ऊपर से टॉप टॉप बॉटम सर्च
करती थी एक बोतल सर्च करती है अब एक लाइन
नंबर के हिसाब से सर्च करती है ऐसे ही
क्या है की हर एक कमांड की नहीं अपने
हिसाब से उसको बनाया गया है इस हिसाब से
रिटायरमेंट के साथ उसको उसे किया जाता है
अलग-अलग कमांड को लेकिन जितने भी कमांड
हमने कल लास्ट दे फोन में जब हम डिस्कस की
थी एक सीरीज मैंने मेंशन की थी जिसको हम
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं जी पे डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं उनका अपने अपने फिल्म में अपना
अपना रोल ठीक है क्योंकि
वो अपना जगह सही है उसे और उसे ऑप्शन को
उसे किया जाता है क्योंकि एक कमांड की एक
पट्टी में कम तक ही उसके अहमियत है उसके
बाद क्या हो जाता है की उसकी लिमिटेशंस ए
जाति है उसे इमिटेशन का फूल फूल करने के
लिए दूसरी कमांड आई है तो साड़ी चीज
जैसे-जैसे डिस्कस करते चलेंगे वैसे जैसे
हमें पता चल जाएगा की किस कमांड को हमें
कितना प्रेफरेंस कितना प्रिपेयर करना
चाहिए कितना नहीं करना चाहिए और मैं जो
अभी बता रहा हूं की 10 तू 15 कमांड्स है
बहुत ज्यादा मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड है
क्योंकि अगर आपने ये कर लिया है उसके बाद
आप कहानी भी कुछ भी कम करोगे लेकिन इसके
ऊपर आपके लिए कम बहुत ही आसन हो जाएगा
क्योंकि आपका कम रियल में बहुत आसन हो
जाएगा चलो बात करते हैं की हम
जो ये गैप कमांड है इसको उसे कैसे कर सकते
हैं पैटर्न को कैसे सर्च कर सकते हैं इसके
बड़े में काफी दीप बताऊंगा आप सबको
नेक्स्ट मैं जितने भी इसके फ्लेक्स उसके
बड़े में आपको बताने की कोशिश करूंगा
चलो बात करते हैं ग्रह कमांड का सीधा सा
उसे किया जाता है की ग्राफ कमांड यूज्ड तू
सर्च पैटर्न इन अन्य फाइल और अन्य कमांड
इसका सिंटेक्स क्या होता है मैं आपको अगर
स्टेन पर दिखाऊं इसका सिंटेक्स होता है
गैप
उसके बाद आपको क्या है ऑप्शंस प्रोवाइड
करने पढ़ते हैं जो ऑप्शन देना चाहते हो
अगर एप्स के ग्रेप्स के साथ ऑप्शन उसके
बाद आप क्या देते हो वो पैटर्न जो आप जवाब
करना चाहते हो
जिसको आप सर्च करना चाहते हो पैटर्न उसके
बाद आप देते हो फाइल का नाम या पांच फाइल
नाम
उसके बाद 5 सिंबल उसके बाद
ग्रेप उसके बाद आप उसे करने वाले ऑप्शन
उसके बाद अब डॉग पाठ या पैटर्न अब डॉग
पैटर्न
मैच हुआ जिसने उसे उसे लाइन को आपकी
स्क्रीन के सामने प्रिंट कर दिया अब देखिए
की समथिंग 2017 लाइन की यह जो फाइल थी
इसमें से कितना इजी हो गया एक पर्टिकुलर
पैटर्न को ग्रैब करना अब हम चाहते हैं की
जी भी पैटर्न को हम सर्च
स्क्रीन पर सो की मैं देखना चाहता हूं की
मुझे उसकी लाइन नंबर भी देखनी है ऐसा नहीं
की मुझे पता ही नहीं चल रहा की अब ये जो
पैटर्न मैंने गैप किया है की कौन सी लाइन
नंबर में ग्रैब किया है अगर मुझे यह भी
जानना है तो सिंपली इसके लिए मैं फ्लैग
उसे करूंगा
पैटर्न का नाम रूट उसके बाद फाइल का नाम
डेमो
तू थी जिसमें आपको रूट वाला पैरामीटर
पैटर्न मिला है एक लाइन नंबर 390
समय इस पैटर्न को इसने
काउंट करना चाहता हूं मैं स्क्रीन पर क्या
करना चाहता हूं टोटल नंबर ऑफ लाइन
काउंट करके लिखना चाहता हूं की कितनी टोटल
लाइन है जिनके अंदर इस पैटर्न को ग्रैब
किया गया है यार इस पैटर्न को डिटेक्टर
किया गया है इस पर्टिकुलर लोग फाइल के
अंदर तो वो कैसे कर सकता हूं उसके लिए एक
ऑप्शन होता है गैप आईफोन सी और अब मैं उसे
करूंगा रूट अब उसका डेमो डॉट टी एक्स टी
एक्स टी
ऐसी 12 लाइन है
मुझे क्या करना था की मुझे लाइन नंबर
यह रूट पैटर्न आपको दिखाई दे रहा है अब
बात करते हैं की मुझे अब मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं की अब दूसरा पैटर्न सर्च
कर रहा हूं
अब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
अभी तो सोचिए की यह जो डीएस है यह क्या
स्मॉल में है अगर इनमें से कोई डीएस शब्द
कैपिटल में होता है उसको क्या करता है यह
ग्राफी नहीं करता क्योंकि आप सबको पहले से
ही पता है की लाइनेक्स एक कैसे सेंसेटिव
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
पर जो भी आप इसके सामने लिखोगे
इसमें सिंगल को के अंदर है डबल को के अंदर
यह आपकी क्या करते हैं स्क्रीन पे प्रिंट
आउट कर देगी उसको सिंपली
देता हूं
इसके अंदर
को क्या करना है
तो उसके लिए मुझे ऑप्शन उसे करना पड़ेगा
कहां जैसे की मैं यहां पर
डीएस कैपिटल में भी था उनको उसको भी उसने
क्या कर दिया आपकी स्क्रीन पर आउटपुट में
शो कर दिया क्योंकि जरूरी नहीं है की जो
हम पैटर्न गैप करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं
की वो स्मॉल में ही हो हो सकता है कैपिटल
में हो जो हम ढूंढने की कोशिश करो इसलिए
हमने क्या किया सेंसटिविटी थी उसको क्या
कर दिया इग्नोर
इग्नोर कर दिया अब क्या कहना की हम चाहते
हैं की जहां जहां पर भी आपको क्या है की
अब हमें क्या किया है जो एग्जांपल ल कर
लिया था की अब हम चाहते हैं की जहां पर
रूट अवेलेबल है अब मुझे क्या वो लाइन नहीं
चाहिए मुझे ओनली क्या करना है की इस शब्द
को प्रिंट करना है ओनली इस शब्द को जो
पैटर्न है इस को प्रिंट करना है वो मैं
कैसे कर सकता हूं
उसके लिए उसे करता हूं और पैटर्न रूट मेरा
उसके बाद है
पुरी लाइन को प्रिंट नहीं किया लेकिन जी
जी लाइन में रूट था उसको उसने क्या कर
दिया उसे पैटर्न के साथ ओनली इस के साथ
इसने प्रिंट कर दिया अब इसका बेनिफिट क्या
है की हम अगर इसको कहानी पर से करना चाहते
हैं ओनली इसी पट्टी को पैटर्न को हम कर
सकते हैं
कुछ करना चाहते हैं तो उसे टाइप से
अब बात करते हैं की इनवर्ट एक इनवर्ट मैच
कैसे कर सकते हैं मतलब जी पैटर्न को मैच
करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं की उसे पैटर्न
को छोड़कर छोड़कर बाकी सब को प्रिंट कर
दिया आपकी स्क्रीन के ऊपर वह कैसे कर सकते
हैं मैंने क्या किया गैप किया आईफोन मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं मैंने और रूट रूट को
छोड़कर मैंने डेमो रोटी स्ट के अंदर सब
कुछ अपने स्क्रीन में क्या कहना चाहता हूं
अब मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस को आप एक साथ उसे कर
सकते थे यहां पर मैंने क्या समझा दिया की
आप लोगों अभी तक क्या बताया की आईफोन आई
कैसे इन सेंसेटिव को कैसे अब क्या कर सकते
हो कैसे सेंसेटिव इनसेंसेटिव कर सकते हो
लाइन नंबर के साथ कैसे प्रिंट कर सकते हो
ओनली काउंट करना चाहता है
ओनली आप उसे पैटर्न को ही प्रिंट करना था
तो अपनी स्क्रीन पर या एडरवाइज आप क्या
करना चाहते हो इनवर्टर मैच इन डी सेंस की
आप पर्टिकुलर कीवर्ड को छोड़कर बाकी सब
कुछ स्क्रीन पर देखना चाहते हैं तो वो भी
आप कर सकते हो ये किस कैसे में उसे कर
सकते हो सकता है की आपके पास एक छोटी सी
फाइल है आपको क्या करना है की उन्हीं
उन्हीं को आपने जैसे की एग्जांपल ले सकते
हैं स्कूल में अटेंडेंस रजिस्टर
या एक प्रेजेंट थी तो ओके एक-एक करके मैं
क्या करूंगा इस को हाईलाइट करूंगा उसके
अलावा मैं क्या कर रहा हूं उसको छोड़ के
बाकी सब को क्या कर रहा हूं मैं प्रिंट कर
रहा हूं लाइक डेट ऐसा एग्जांपल हम ले सकते
हैं यहां पर
बात करते हो उसका एक और यूजफुल कैसे दिखता
हूं आपको कैसे हम उसे कर सकते हैं अब जैसे
ये पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या कर रहा हूं की एक
मैंने यूजर एड किया
मनीष एम ए एन आई एस हा मनीष कर दिया मनीषा
डाउनलोडिंग
ओनली ये मनीष देखना है मुझे इससे कोई मतलब
नहीं है मुझे क्या एग्जैक्ट मैच करना है
अगर मैं बिल्कुल एग्जिट मैच
पैटर्न है और यही पैटर्न है अगर आप
एग्जैक्ट मैच करना चाहते हो उसके लिए भी
एक ब्लैक उसे किया जाता है
आईफोन ब्लू उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया मनीष
मनीष
प्रिंट हो गया मनीष उसके बाद
स्लैश्यूडी ये टेंडर कर दिया अब आपको
देखिए की ये ओनली एग्जिट मैच के साथ आपके
पैटर्न को आउटपुट में शो करेगा
अब और बात करते हैं देखो अब मैंने क्या
करना है की अभी तक मैंने क्या किया की जो
पैटर्न मैंने क्रॉप किया इसने इस को
स्क्रीन के ऊपर आउटपुट में शो कर दिया अब
हो सकता है की मैं देखना चाहता हूं की जो
मेरी लोग फाइल है मैं देखना चाहता हूं की
जो पैटर्न मैंने गलत किया उससे थोड़े से
कर पांच लाइन ऊपर की देखना चाहता हूं
चार-पांच लाइन नीचे से भी देखना चाहता हूं
तो वह मैं कैसे देख सकता हूं उसके लिए भी
कुछ ऑप्शंस होते हैं जैसे की मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं
डीएस उसके बाद
कौन सी लाइन नंबर है
1557 नंबर लाइन नंबर है मैं देखना चाहता
हूं की
1557 से ऊपर चार-पांच और लाइन देखना चाहता
हूं देखना चाहता हूं की किस टाइप्स की है
लोग बनी हुई है क्या और भी कुछ मुझे मिल
सकता है इसे रिलेटेड तो मैं कैसे करूंगा
छिपकली मैं कहूंगा ग्राफ और हिफिन एन उसके
बाद मैंने क्या किया आईफोन ए ए का मतलब
क्या होता है आप आफ्टर
ठीक है सॉरी मैं पहले बिफोर देखना चाहता
हूं
उसके बाद में कितनी लाइन देखना चाहता हूं
कर लाइन देखना चाहता हूं
डीएस उसके बाद
इसके साथ में जो कर लाइन और थी इनको आप
क्या आउटपुट के साथ प्रिंट कर दिया अब मैं
क्या चाहता हूं की नहीं मैं
1557 जो लाइन में दी एन एस आपको दिखाई दे
रहा है मुझे इससे नीचे कर लाइन और देखनी
है मैं बिफोर नहीं देगा आफ्टर देखना चाहता
हूं की आफ्टर में क्या है तो वो भी मैं
देख सकता हूं सिंपली यहां पर क्या करूंगा
मैं कैपिटल ए उसे करूंगा तो ये आपको दिखे
जाएगा एक इंटर अब देखिए 1557 के बाद में
भी कर लाइन है मैंने शो कर दी की हां इसके
बाद ये है लोग में इसके बाद यह है इसके
बाद ये है इससे मैं क्या है मैं ज्यादा
क्लियर हो जाऊंगा की मैं एक्चुअल में जो
फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं
सही में मुझे वो मिल रहा है या नहीं
मुझे क्या करना है की जी पैटर्न को मैं
गैप कर रहा हूं उसे पैटर्न से
कर लाइन ऊपर और कर लाइन नीचे एक साथ देखना
चाहता हूं तो उसके लिए भी एक फ्लैग होता
है सिंपली आप क्या करोगे
क्या करना है आप सिंपली उसे करोगे कैपिटल
सी और उसके बाद
कर लाइन ऊपर कर लाइन
कीजिए अब देखिए इसमें जो पैटर्न मैच किया
था उसे पैटर्न से कर लाइन ऊपर वाली लाइन
को शो कर दिया और कर लाइन नीचे वाली लाइन
को आपकी स्क्रीन के आउटपुट पर शो कर दिया
अब देखो चीज दिखता हूं आप लोगों को की अगर
कोई भी आपकी इसमें मशीन में अगर स्पेस
सेपरेट
पैटर्न है जिसको आपको ग्राफ करना है आपकी
इसमें लोग फाइल में तो वो कैसे करोगे
स्पेस सेपरेटेड को ऐसे नहीं कर सकते की
मैंने क्या किया ग्राफ किया अब मैंने
लगाया की एक और एग्जांपल मैंने अभी इसमें
होगी या नहीं होगी पहले इसके अंदर में एड
कर देता हूं
800 कर दिया मैंने इसको भी एड कर दिया अब
मैं क्या करता हूं गैप करना चाहता हूं इसी
को कैसे करूंगा आप सिंपली क्या करोगे और
मैंने क्या किया
और डीएस और उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया
नाम उसके बाद में क्या कर रहा हूं
डीएस नाम और उसके बाद में सिंपली फाइल का
नाम
है अभी लेटेस्ट वर्जन के साथ गैप को भी
क्या किया है अपडेट किया गया है तो अब ये
कम कर रहा है बट क्या है
अगर ओन्ली स्पेस अप्रेटेड वाली लाइन
और
डायरेक्टली इसको नहीं मिली सिंपली ये क्या
कर रहा है की कैसे इन सेंसेटिव है जो भी
है इसने डीएस ज्यादा पैरामीटर स्पेस
एपेरेडनेस सबको क्या कर दिया यहां पर आपके
स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर दिया बट क्या है
की अगर आपने स्पेस सेपरेटेड दे दिया तो
इसने इसको समझा ये एक फाइल है और ये दूसरी
फाइल है लेकिन अगर इस टाइप के आपको
सर्चिंग करनी है तो आप कैसे करोगे जैसे की
मैं क्या करना है उसके बाद 5
लिया मैंने उसके बाद मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं
डीएस नाम उसके बाद अगर मैं सर्च करता हूं
क्लियर तो इस तरीके से अगर आप किसी भी
पैटर्न को स्पेस
करना चाहते हैं तो आप इस तरीके से कर सकते
हैं
अब बात करते हैं आगे बढ़ते हैं इसी में
अब मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं की मैंने सबसे
पहले जो पैटर्न था जो रूट वाला मैंने
लॉक फाइल में मैंने क्या किया था सर्च
करने की कोशिश की थी अब मैं क्या चाहता
हूं की मैं सिर्फ उन लाइन को प्रिंट करना
चाहता हूं जिसके बिकिनी में मेरा वो
पर्टिकुलर पैटर्न है पर एग्जांपल मैंने
रूट लिया था जिसके बिगनिंग रूट है सिर्फ
19 लाइन को मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
प्रिंट करना चाहता हूं बाकी को नहीं करना
चाहता तो मैं कैसे करूंगा उसके लिए कमांड
होती है ग्राफ उसके बाद सिंगल को या डबल
को कुछ भी दे सकते हो उसके बाद आप ग्रेटर
दें सिम यह
ऊपर होगा यह वाला
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है रूट पैटर्न का
नाम सिंपली उसके बाद क्या करना आपको फाइल
का नाम लिखना डायमंड
को आपके सामने प्रिंट किया जबकि लास्ट
टाइम जब मैंने स्टार्टिंग में रूठ को
प्रिंट करवाया था पैटर्न को किसने 12 से
13 लाइन को प्रिंट किया था लेकिन अब नहीं
किया क्योंकि अभी मैंने स्पेशली उसको बोला
है की जी लाइन के स्टार्टिंग में यह
पैटर्न है सिर्फ इस लाइन को प्रिंट करना
है अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं की जी लाइन के
एंडिंग में अगर यह पैटर्न है मैं सिर्फ
उसको
क्या करना चाहता हूं सर्च करना चाहता हूं
सिंपली मैं क्या करूंगा
डॉलर तो जी लाइन के और में यह पैटर्न होगा
यह उसको क्या कर देगा
बट इसने कुछ भी शो नहीं किया क्योंकि किसी
भी लाइन के और में यह पैटर्न नहीं है अगर
मैं अगर और कोई पैटर्न सर्च करता हूं पर
एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं
बट
इंटर करता हूं तो यह भी कोई पैटर्न नहीं
है तो मुझे ज्यादा पता नो लोग इन जरूर
मिलेगा
नो लोग इन
इंटरेस्ट अब इस फाइल में जी जी लाइन के
लास्ट में
उसने क्या कर दिया आपके स्क्रीन के आउटपुट
में शो कर दिया अब नेक्स्ट यह तो मैंने
बता दिया आपको की अगर जी स्टार्टिंग से जो
पैटर्न है उसे लाइन में अगर वह कैसे
प्रिंट करना है और एंडिंग से कैसे प्रिंट
करना है आपको पता चल गया होगा अब बात करते
हैं
यहां पर मैं एक और आप लोगों के कहना एक
प्रैक्टिस क्वेश्चन देता हूं अगर आप लोग
जैसे की कल मैं इसे भी सब एक या दो
स्टूडेंट ने किया है बाकी आप लोग भी मर्जी
आप करना चाहे तो कर सकते हो अगर आप लोग
लगता है की जो आपका टाइम वेस्ट है आपके
पास टाइम नहीं है तो डोंट राइट मैं आपको
पोस्ट नहीं करूंगा नहीं मैं आपको कुछ
कहूंगा तो उसके लिए अगर आप चाहे तो कर
सकते हो मैं आप लोगों को दे देता हूं
प्रैक्टिस क्वेश्चन
क्या है
पर्टिकुलर
पैटर्न
आपको फाइंड आउट करना है
पहले
[संगीत]
नंबर
जो आपको क्या करना है की
25 से लाइन नंबर 35 के बीच में कोई पैटर्न
शूज कीजिए अपनी मर्जी से आपको क्या करना
है आपको वह पैटर्न क्या करना है आपके
स्क्रीन पर आउटपुट में शो करवाना है ग्रेप
कमांड की हेल्प से कंडीशन यहां पर यह है
की आपको पुरी की पुरी फाइल को ग्रेप नहीं
करना है सब 225 तू 25 क्या करना है आपको
गैप करना है और इसी के अंदर क्या वो
पैटर्न सर्च करना है वो कैसे करोगे कैसे
नहीं करोगे यह आप जानते हो तो इसका जो
आउटपुट रहेगा कमांड जो कमांड आप उसे करोगे
वीडियो कंप्लीट होने के बाद क्लास कंप्लीट
होने के बाद उसके कमेंट क्षेत्र में उसको
क्या कर सकते आप भेज सकते हो जैसे लास्ट
क्लास में जिसने भेजो था उसके लिए
है उसने किया है बाकी किसी को आता नहीं
किसी ने किया नहीं तो इसका मतलब
अब कंटिन्यू करते हैं जैसे की एक अलग
सीपीयू जो आपकी आर्किटेक्चर को क्या करती
है शो करती है
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं इस पैटर्न को
पैटर्न है इसको मैं क्या कहना चाहता हूं
ग्राफ करना चाहता हूं वो कैसे करें करूंगा
देखो मैं क्या कैसे करूंगा ल एस सी पी ओ
कमांड मैंने उसे की
पाइप सिंबल उसके बाद ग्राफ उसके बाद इस
आईफोन कैसे
मैंने अपने स्क्रीन पर लिख दिया यह पैटर्न
जो मैं सर्च करना चाहता हूं
सिंपली मैंने क्या कर दिया की टेंडर अब
देखो इतनी बड़ी फाइल्स में से इन सब इसी
को आपके स्क्रीन पर आउटपुट में शो कर दिया
कितनी हेल्पफुल है कितने इजी कम कर दिया
आपकी जो आउटपुट आपकी स्क्रीन में देखना
चाहते हो अगर आप किसी को रिपोर्ट बनाना
चाहते हो किसी रिपोर्ट में मेंशन करना
चाहते हो की सिर्फ लेकिन अब उसे रिपोर्ट
में सारे मटर आप मेंशन नहीं करना तो इस
तरीके से आप गैप करके उसे पैरामीटर को
क्या कर सकते हो स्क्रीन पे एक फाइल के
अंदर से करके किसी को भी आपको रिपोर्ट
बनके दे सकते हो अब मुझे वही है की अगर ये
रहा
सीपीयू ऑप्टिमाइजर एक मॉडल मॉडल नाम अगर
मुझे इस मॉडल नाम को क्या करना है अगर आप
करना है मॉडल नाम वगैरा करने के लिए अभी
स्पेस है तो मैं पहले बता चुका हूं कैसे
करेंगे एलसीपीओ आईफोन आई मुझे उसे नहीं
करना चाहिए
अब मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं मॉडल आगे मैं
डायरेक्टली ऐसे लिखूंगा तो ये आपको जो
चाहिए आउटपुट में नहीं मिलेगा सिंपली मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं डबल कोटिया के अंदर एड
कर देता अब देखिए इसमें क्या कर दिया मॉडल
बायस मॉडल नाम या जो भी है की इसमें आपकी
स्क्रीन पर दो को प्रिंट आउट करके दिखा
दिया अब यही पर क्या है यह तो था की आप
कैसे ग्रेप को और भी अच्छे तरीके से उसे
कर सकते हो ये ये साड़ी चीज आपको लाइव में
देखने को मिलती है अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं
की मैं मल्टीपल पैटर्न को सर्च करना चाहता
हूं मल्टीपल पैटर्न में कैसे सर्च करूंगा
क्योंकि एक हर बार थोड़ी ना की मैं एक
पैटर्न को करूंगा फिर कमांड फायर करूंगा
फिर मैं दूसरे पैटर्न को उसे करूंगा फिर
कमांड फायर फोन नो आई डोंट वांट आईटी मा
जाता हूं की मुझे मल्टीपल पैटर्न को सर्च
करना है उसके लिए कैसे करेंगे देखो अगर आप
मैंने किया और अब क्या करोगे आपने क्या कर
दिया मैं डेमो रोटी एक्सट्रीम में रूट भी
सर्च करना चाहता हूं और मैं
एफटीपी भी सर्च करना चाहता हूं और डीएस भी
सर्च करना चाहता हूं सिंपली डेमो
कर दिया अब इसने एक्चुअल में कम नहीं किया
है क्योंकि पहले यह हम देख चुके हैं इसमें
ओनली रूट एक ही जो पैटर्न है इसको ध्यान
में रखते हुए क्या समझा फाइल नाम समझा अब
इसने नाम की कोई फाइल नहीं है
फाइल है जिसके अंदर आपको यहां इन लाइन के
अंदर आपको पैटर्न देखने को मिला है तो
भैया अब हम कैसे करेंगे मुझे तो मल्टीपल
पैटर्न को सर्च करना है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा तो इस कम को करने के लिए हमें
कमांड का उसे करते हैं
मैं देखा था आपको
उसे करते हैं इस पैटर्न को मल्टीपल पैटर्न
को सर्च करने के लिए
कमांड में सिर्फ एक ही डिफरेंस है वो है
की ग्रेप्स सिंगल पैटर्न को सर्च कर सकता
है बल्कि यह कमांड क्या कर शक्ति है
मल्टीपल पैटर्न को सर्च कर शक्ति है एक
फाइल के अंदर इसके अलावा कोई भी डिफरेंस
नहीं है सारे फ्लैग से उसे किया जाते हैं
आउटपुट से आता है बिल्कुल कोई भी डिफरेंस
नहीं सिर्फ एक ही डिफरेंस है सिंगल पैटर्न
और मल्टीपल पैटर्न का अब जैसे की मुझे
क्या करना है इन तीनों पैटर्न को अगर इस
फाइल के अंदर सर्च करना चाहता था मैं कैसे
करूंगा
उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा
सिंगल को उसके जैसे की रूट और पाइप सिंबल
उसके अलावा एफटीपी पाइप सिंबल और दी एन एस
और उसके बाद में क्या करना फाइल का नाम
डेमोक्रेसी और उसे कर लेट हूं
डीएस वाले पैटर्न को भी इसने स्क्रीन पर
शो कर दिया और रूट वाले को भी और हालांकि
शायद इसमें एफटीपी नहीं है तो इसलिए
एफटीपी पैटर्न कुछ नहीं गायब करके नहीं
दिखाई दिया दिखाए आपको स्क्रीन के ऊपर
इस तरीके से हम क्या कर सकते हैं मल्टीपल
पैटर्न को भी सर्च कर सकते हैं लेकिन क्या
है
बिल्कुल से रहेगी अगर मैं इसका मतलब क्या
उसके लिए हम एक स्पेशल एक एडवांस ऑप्शन का
उसे करना पड़ता है
लेकिन अगर आपको लगता है की मैं मल्टीपल
ऑप्शंस करने के लिए तो अब कमांड के साथ
कैसे कर सकते हो
के साथ हम करेंगे
अब मैंने क्या किया इसके अंदर दिया रूट
और
उसके बाद में क्या कर रहा हूं
मल्टीपल पैटर्न को सर्च किया किसी भी फाइल
के अंदर अब मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं की एक
पैटर्न सर्च
अगर मैं चाहूं तो इसको ग्रेप के साथ में
उसे कर सकता हूं लेकिन मैं एक बार आपको
उसे करके दिखता हूं
देखो मैंने क्या किया एफ जी में किया जाता
हूं रूट रूट
इसी के अंदर एक तो पार्ट डी वाली फाइल
इसके अंदर सर्च करना चाहता हूं एक
फ्लैश सीटीसी के अंदर एक मेरी फाइल होती
है ग्रुप ग्रुप नाम की इसको मैं बताऊंगा
जी आर ओ यू पी वेरी डिटेल ग्रुप नाम की
पायल होती है इसके अंदर सर्च करना चाहता
हूं और एक स्लाइस सीटीसी के अंदर एक और
होती है
सर्च करना चाहता हूं
[संगीत]
तो वह भी कर सकता हूं कैसे करूं
आईफोन अप कैपिटल अप उसके बाद मैं क्या
करूंगा
उसके बाद स्लैश ईटीसी स्लैश ग्रुप
और सिंपली टेंडर तो तब भी ये से ही कम
करेगा जैसे लास्ट लास्ट कमांड के साथ किया
था एक और चीज बताता हूं तो लेकिन जो
लेटेस्ट ग्रेप्स है अभी जो ये कमांड कम
करते हैं इस मशीन के ऊपर अभी क्या है की
बाय डिफॉल्टर इसके साथ क्या कर दिया ये
मर्ज कर दिया गया है
देने की जरूर नहीं है पर सिंपली अगर
विदाउट हिफिन अप ऑप्शन भी इसको उसे करता
हूं तो यह आपको स्क्रीन पर शो करेगा तो
सिंपली बात है
चलेगा क्योंकि जो वेब कमांड है उसके अंदर
इंटीग्रेटेड कर दिया गया है फ्लैग को अब
आपको अलग से उसको मेंशन करने की जरूर नहीं
है लेकिन अगर ये है की आपको क्या करना है
फ्लैग को तो उसे करना ही पड़ेगा अगर आपको
मल्टीपल पैटर्न को सर्च करना चाहते हो मैं
एक ही सिंगल फाइल के अंदर अब मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं अगर मैंने क्या किया की एक चीज और
करके देखा था आपके सामने मैंने क्या किया
एक गैप किया उसके बाद हाय फैन मैंने चलो
किया उसके बाद एफ और फी किया और सबको पता
है इसका मतलब क्या है और मैं का रहा हूं
इसके बाद रूट रूट के अंदर मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं एफटीपी
उसके बाद में क्या कर रहा हूं
की मल्टीपल पैटर्न
मल्टीपल फाइल्स या सिंगल फाइल पर कम नहीं
करता मल्टीपल पैटर्न के लिए ग्राफ्ट को
अगर उसे करना तो उसके लिए आपको हिफिन
ऑप्शन देना पड़ेगा
तो आपको ये आपको आउटपुट अच्छे से सो रहे
हैं जो आपको चाहिए होता था तो यह चीज थी
की गैप कमांड के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन की आप
कैसे उसको उसे कर सकते हो अब मैं कुछ चीज
बताऊं की आपके सामने एक प्रॉब्लम ए जाति
है जैसे की हम फाइल का पाठ ही भूल गए जी
फाइल को मैं सर्च करना चाहता था उसका मैं
बात भूल गया अब मुझे सिर्फ इतना याद है की
हां किसी के अंदर एक डिफॉल्ट डिफॉल्ट नाम
का एक फोल्डर है उसके अंदर बहुत साड़ी
फाइल्स है और उनमें से किसी एक फाइल है वो
पैटर्न किसी भी एक फाइल में या पर्टिकुलर
वही फाइल है वो पैटर्न किसी एक में लेकिन
इस बात तक वह गारंटी दे रहा है
लेकिन उसके बाद उसे मालूम नहीं की वो कहां
पर है
अगर वह मैं फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं तो
मैं कैसे करूंगा उसके लिए एक ऑप्शन होता
है अगर आप गैप करोगे तो मैं आपको मेरे पास
है उसका एक एग्जांपल नहीं है अभी
प्रेजेंटली दिमाग में ए नहीं रहा तो
ग्रेप्स करो हिफिन कैपिटल आर उसे करोगे
पैटर्न
और जितना पाठ आपको पता है लगता है तो
स्लैश ईटीसी पर एग्जांपल
ये क्या करेगा की पहले सीआईडी इसी में
सर्च आउट करेगा डिफॉल्ट्स के अंदर इसके
बाद क्या की जितने भी ये का के रिकवरी का
मतलब सिंपली हर एक के अंदर ये इस पैटर्न
को सर्च करता हो जाएगा उसके बाद आपका
आउटपुट स्क्रीन पर शो कर देगा
कमांड के बड़े में और
सीधी सरिता एडिटर कमांड के बड़े में
इनफॉरमेशन तो आई हो सबको यहां तक समझ में
ए गया होगा एक बार चाट में बता दीजिए किसी
को लगता है की यह तीन दोनों चीज समझ में
नहीं आई
एक बार चाट में बता दीजिए
[संगीत]
ठीक है तो आज के लिए इतना रखते हैं हम
क्या करेंगे की आज दो ही चीज पढ़ाएंगे
इतनी चीज अब ज्यादा नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि
वह फायदा नहीं जितने जिनको पढ़ना उतना ही
आएंगे
क्योंकि
मुझे पता है की कोई वैल्यू नहीं होती
हमें पता है
ना उसको ऐसे समझते हैं की बस नहीं वह तो
बस आपके
कंटेंट को इतना पावरफुल बनाया है की हमने
टाइम पास नहीं किया है
तो
नो प्रॉब्लम क्योंकि हमने जो स्टार्ट किया
मैं कहानी भी कुछ भी करके आपको मैं डिलीवर
करता है
वहां पर आप क्या अटेंडेंस भी प्रोवाइड
करते हो वहीं पर
क्या होता है क्योंकि
[संगीत]
रिकॉर्डिंग दिखेगा मैं बोलना हूं की सचमुच
जरूर नहीं करते
क्या हम आपको लाइव सरिता प्रोवाइड करके
हम वो चीज प्रोवाइड एक क्या करना है की हम
एक पैटर्न में पढ़ा रहे हैं सो डेट की आप
लोग अपने फिल्में धीरे-धीरे जब इस चैनल से
हमारे साथ जुड़कर जुड़ने जब साड़ी चीज कर
लोग तो आपको एक दिन एहसास होगा की हमने
क्या शिखा आपने साथ क्योंकि हमें पता है
की किस तरीके से आपको आगे जाना है किस
तरीके से आप लोगों को पढ़ना है इस तरीके
से आपको करना चाहिए किससे आपको सीखना है
वे आर डी एक्सपेंड हमें किसी को पांच का
किसी को 7 साल का एक्सपीरियंस है हम
बिल्कुल नहीं नहीं है की यहां पर ऐसे ही
यार आज क्लासिक और आज आपको बता दिया
ठीक है तो हम एक कम करते हैं 10 मिनट का
डाउट सेशन रखते हैं की अभी तक
जो भी कुछ पूछना है इससे रिलेटेड तो अभी
ओपन सेशन है नेक्स्ट 10 मिनट तो आप लोग
पूछ सकते हो लाइव चाट में मैं आपका जवाब
दूंगा
हेलो कुछ भी पूछ सकते हैं आप लोग जहां भी
डाउट है अभी तक दे वन दे तू डिफेक्टिव
डाउट है मुझे समझ नहीं आया मुझे कुछ पूछना
है तो आप पूछ सकते हैं
आपके लिए डाउट सेशन ओपन है अभी
और नेक्स्ट
728 मिनट 5 मिनट 10 मिनट कुछ भी बोल सकते
हैं तो आप चाट में क्वेश्चन कर सकते हैं
हमसे
फोर्थ क्लास में अब्सेंट
करता हूं
[संगीत]
बताइए एक बार
बता दीजिए
हमें एग्जांपल की तो समझने की कोशिश की है
की
जब अपने इसको उसे करोगे तो उसको कैसे उसे
करोगे प्राइवेट और पब्लिक प्लेस में हमने
उसको इस तरीके से बताने को प्राइवेट
पब्लिक प्लेस का मतलब क्या बताया मैंने की
लाइनेक्स में क्या है दो टाइप्स के यूजर
कम करते हैं या तो एक एडमिन ये जो होता है
जिसको हम बोलते हैं रॉटविलर एक होता है
नॉर्मल यूजर्स जिनके पास कोई भी प्रिविलेज
नहीं होते मतलब उनके पास कुछ नहीं जस्ट
नॉर्मल उनको जो कम दिया है वहीं पर कम
करेंगे उसके अलावा कुछ भी कम नहीं कर सकते
मशीन के साथ अब होता क्या है की हमने जो
फाइल सिस्टम हीर की बताया था तो या जब मैं
यह दे वन क्लास लिया था तो मैंने बताया था
की जब
लाइनेक्स है उसमें कुछ अराउंड 17 डायरेक्ट
की मशीन में आई है
है अब वह लाइनेक्स में क्या की हर
डायरेक्ट रिपेयर कुछ ना कुछ परमिशन डिफाइन
बिन डायरेक्टर के ऊपर कुछ परमीशंस डिफाइन
होती हैं और होम
डायरेक्टरी है उसके ऊपर तीनों परमिशन
डिपेंड होती है आप उसके अंदर रेड भी कर
सकते हो राइट भी कर सकते हो और एग्जीक्यूट
भी कर सकते हो तीनों परमीशंस होती हैं उसे
डायरेक्टर के अंदर इसी तरीके से सभी
डायरेक्टर के ऊपर कुछ ना कुछ परमिशन
डिफाइन है अब जो खुद का होम अकाउंट है जो
होम डायरेक्टरी है उसको प्राइवेट प्लेस
बोला गया है और उसके बाद चाय आप नॉर्मल
यूजर हो चाहे आप रोटी करो उसके बाद पूरा
पब्लिक प्लेस बोला गया है
आप अपने घर में कुछ भी कर सकते हो कोई भी
फाइल क्रिएट कर सकते हो कोई भी फाइल डिलीट
कर सकते हो
आपको पूरा अधिकार है उसके अंदर कुछ भी कर
सकते हो अपने होम अकाउंट के अंदर वह आपका
घर है
तापमान के चलोगे अब बात हुई पब्लिक प्लेस
की पब्लिक प्लेस में आपको क्या है यह
साड़ी चीज करने का कोई भी हक नहीं है आपको
सिंपली पब्लिक प्लेस की तरह ही बिहेव करना
है जहां पर जो आपको परमीशंस है आप उन्हें
के अनुसार ही कम करोगे
उसके अलावा आपको कम
अपनी मर्जी से नहीं कर सकते किसी भी
डायरेक्टर के अंदर अगर किसी की डायरेक्टर
के अंदर बोला गया है की आपको रीड ओनली
परमिशन रेड ओनली का मतलब क्या की उसके
कंटेंट को हम देख सकते हो पढ़ सकते हो
लेकिन उसके अंदर ना कोई मोडिफिकेशन कर
सकते ना उसके अंदर कुछ चेंज कर सकते हैं
अगर किसी डायरेक्टर पर ये परमीशंस है वह
क्या पब्लिक प्लेस है उसको कौन चेंज कर
सकता है उसको उसका एडमिन चेंज कर सकता है
उसके अलावा कोई भी उसको चेंज नहीं कर सकता
जो लो रिफाइंड है अगर हम जनरल की अगर आप
अपने घर में चाहे तो कुछ भी कर सकते लेकिन
जब आप एक
बाहर ए जाते हो अपने घर के बाहर तो आपको
क्या की सोसाइटी के रूल के हिसाब से रहना
पड़ता है उसके बाद सड़क पे ए जाते तो आपको
रोड ट्रैफिक रूल्स फॉलो करने पढ़ते हैं
उसके बाद आपको क्या की किसी इंसान से बात
करनी है कुछ भी प्रॉब्लम होती उसके बाद
क्या की बहुत सारे लोगों को खोल कर फॉलो
करना पड़ता है इस प्रकार से क्या है
क्लीनिक क्यों अगर आप आउटर वर्ल्ड से उसको
कंपेयर करोगे तो बेसिकली आपका कम होम और
लेने इसका होम इस तरह ट्वीट होंगे
प्राइवेट प्लेस की तरह और जैसे की आप अपने
घर से बाहर निकाल तो ऐसे ही लाइनेक्स में
आप अपने घर से बाहर निकलोगे तो वो आपका
पब्लिक प्लेस है वहां पर क्या है पुरी
डिफरेंट ब्लाउज है उनको आपको फॉलो ही करना
पड़ेगा क्योंकि वो आपके ऊपर फोर्स किया गए
हैं उनको आप नहीं कर सकते अगर उन लोगों के
साथ छेड़कुन कर सकता है
ओबवियसली बात आपको पता है की अगर बाहर अगर
सिविल है उसके बाद कंपेयर करते हो आप अपने
अलावा तो गवर्नमेंट इसी प्रकार से
गवर्नमेंट कौन है
रोटर है जो उसका एडमिन है तो आई होप की
आपको समझ में आया होगा अच्छे से की पब्लिक
और प्राइवेट प्लेस क्या है क्योंकि जब तक
ये अगर आपके दिमाग में क्लियर होगी की
कहां पर मकान कर सकता हूं कहां पर नहीं कर
सकता तो आप कभी भी कोई भी किसी भी फाइल के
साथ कम करोगे तो आपको प्रॉब्लम नहीं होने
वाली इन फ्यूचर कभी भी क्योंकि आपको एक मन
सेट क्लियर हो जाएगी की किस डायरेक्टरी
में मैं कम कर सकता हूं क्या नहीं कर सकता
और जब भी कम करोगे तो आपको काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग भी लगेगा तथा'एस वही आई होप
की प्रिंस आपको नेटवर्क कमेंट बता दीजिए
की आपको क्लियर हो गया होगा
अन्य ऑथर क्वेश्चन किसी की तरफ से
अभी भी समझ में आया नहीं आया
ओके थैंक यू प्रिंस तो अब उसे चीज को नहीं
आप आसपास की चीजों के साथ कंपेयर करोगे ना
जो आसपास जहां आप रहते हो घर हो कैसे भी
तो चाहे वो साइबर सिक्योरिटी ऐसा है एक
बार आप उन चीजों को
अब की बाहर की दुनिया साथ कंपेयर करना सिख
जाओगे ना तो आपको जो कंप्यूटर वर्ल्ड होता
है साइबर सिक्योरिटी कोई चलो शब्द को छोड़
के अगर आप पूरे अपने पीसी वर्ल्ड को
समझोगे उसे पीसी के अंदर जो भी कम करते हो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होगा प्रोग्रामिंग हुई या
कुछ भी होगा जैसे की
कम कर रहे हो तो अगर उसके अंदर जी टाइप्स
की अगर आपको सही से कोई पढ़ा रहा है कोई
बता रहा है कांसेप्चुअल नॉलेज दे रहा है
उसे कॉन्सेप्ट को अपने नॉर्मल जब के जो कम
करते उसके साथ अगर आप कल लेट करने की
कोशिश करोगे तो आपको बाय गुड सच में ही
बहुत ज्यादा मजा आने वाला है तभी इंटरेस्ट
बंता है एडरवाइज आप बर हो जाओगे और रखते
रहो रखते रहो
वर्ल्ड में कभी भी किसी चीज को रिटर्न
देता हूं सर प्रैक्टिकल कम होता है और
इसके अलावा
कोई भी कम नहीं होता फैक्ट्री
कर पाओगे जब आप उसको अपनी आसपास की चीजों
जुड़ का रहे हो जैसे प्राइवेट पब्लिक
प्लेस को हम सिंपली अपने घर और बाहर के
प्लेस से जोड़ लिया तो कम हमेशा क्या है
की आपकी दिमाग में रहेगा ओके ऐसे कम करना
क्योंकि जैसे आप घर में बिहेव कर सकते हो
ऐसे लाइन इसमें भी होगा सकते हो सिंपल
अगला क्वेश्चन था
सिंपल सिंपली सिंपली ओके
एसटीडी इन और एसटीडी आउट देखो अगर आपने
मेरा फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन का जो टॉपिक पढ़ा
होगा की फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन क्या होता है
की एक टेबल होती है ओपन फाइल्स को ट्रैक
करने के लिए करनाल के द्वारा और वही टेबल
क्या है की अदर प्रोग्राम्स की हेल्प भी
करती है या प्रोसेस की हेल्प भी करती है
ताकि उसे पता चल जाएगी जी फाइल को मैं
एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं जी फाइल
को मैं ओपन करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
यह साड़ी चीज उसे पता चल जाति है
लेकिन यह जो टेबल होती है
इस प्रोसेस में कोई भी मोडिफिकेशन कोई भी
अपडेशन अगर किसी को कुछ भी कम करना है
और जो इसकी जो फर्स्ट थ्री एंट्री होती है
ना वह सब में मिलेंगे आपको क्योंकि आप एक
बात सोचिए की आप अपने स्क्रीन पर कोई भी
कमांड फायर कर रहे हो किस फायर कर रहे हो
स्टैंडर्ड है की अगर आप कुछ भी करोगे उसे
प्रोग्राम के साथ बाय डिफॉल इन कमांड के
लिए जैसे की अभिलेख का एग्जांपल ले रहा
हूं तो वो आपका कीबोर्ड बाय डिफॉल्ट है
क्योंकि जब भी आप उसे कीबोर्ड के अंदर
टाइप करते हो आपकी स्क्रीन पे दिखाई देता
है उसके बाद क्या करते हो जैसे आप इंटर
करते हो मतलब वो एक प्रोसेस होता है आपका
जो भी आपने कमांड फायर की जो भी आपने
कीबोर्ड का इनपुट दिया प्रोसेस होने के
बाद भी अब क्या करते हो वेट करते हो
क्योंकि आप वेट करते हो की मुझे कुछ ना
कुछ मिले तभी तो मुझे पता चलेगा की जो
मैंने कम किया वो हुआ या नहीं हुआ अब वो
कम हुआ इसका मतलब किसका वेट कर रहे हो
अगर आप क्या करने जाओगे ना कभी भी देखना
जब आप किसी को प्रोग्रामिंग आई होगी तो
देखना बाय डिफॉल्ट किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम में जो स्टैंडर्ड इन पैटर्न है वो
कीबोर्ड होता है की बाय डिफॉल्टर आपको जब
भी हेल्प प्रोग्राम
पीसी की स्क्रीन या आपके लैपटॉप की
स्क्रीन वह आपके बाय डिफॉल्ट होते हैं की
आपने कुछ कम किया अब मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा
वो कम हो गया उसको बोलेंगे हम आउटपुट तो
स्टैंडर्ड आउट बाय दीपू ये है आपके एक
कीबोर्ड और एक स्क्रीन पर एसटीडी आई आर ए
आई है जिसको स्टैंडर्ड एरर बोलते हैं अब
भैया आपने कम किया उसमें कुछ एरर ए गई तो
अब वो एरर ए गई तो उसको भी तो डिटेक्टर
करना पड़ेगा ना उसको भी तो पता चलना अगर
एरर आपने उसको आउटपुट शो नहीं किया लड़का
भी तब भी तो प्रॉब्लम है क्योंकि आपको पता
ही नहीं चल रहा है अगर आप वेट कर रहे हो
की हां होगा होगा घंटा तक बैठे हुए हैं तो
अब एरर का भी हमें देखना है कहानी ना
कहानी तो इसलिए उसका भी भाई स्टैंडर्ड जो
मेंटेन किया गया है स्टैंडर्ड हेयर का वो
भी आपकी स्क्रीन ही होती है या टर्मिनल इन
कैसे
करते हो साइबर सिक्योरिटी में कहानी भी तो
क्या करते हो की इन तीनों चीजों को अपने
अकॉर्डिंग
की बजे किसी फाइल का इनपुट दे दो उससे रीड
करेगा आपको आउटपुट दे देगा वो चाहे तो उसे
आउटपुट का क्या करो किसी और का इनपुट बना
दो एसटीडी आउट को किसी को एसटीडी इनका इन
स्टडी का सॉरी एसटीडी आउटपुट जो है
स्टैंडर्ड आउटपुट है उसको किसी का इनपुट
बना दो और इनपुट से जो आउटपुट ए रहा है
उसको अगर आप चाहते हो की मैं नहीं मैं
स्क्रीन पर देख रहे हैं जाता तो उसको किसी
फाइल के अंदर से कर दो तो टोटली आप क्या
कर रहे हो कितनी भी कामना अब स्क्रीन पे
फायर कर रहे हो वो साड़ी की साड़ी इसी भी
हमें कम करें अब देखो मैंने क्या किया हुआ
है की एक कमांड लिखी है यहां पर अगर मैं
सोचूं तो अभी यह रहा यहां पर यह क्या है
एसटीडी आउट ए रहा है स्क्रीन पर यह तो ठीक
है कमांड के ऑप्शंस है कमांड इस हिसाब से
इसके अंदर लॉजिक लगे हुए हैं की मुझे क्या
करना है लेकिन यह देखो ना यह एसटीडी इन है
मैं कीबोर्ड से
मैंने सिर्फ टर्मिनल के लिए लिया था उसके
बाद देखो इस फाइल से लिया मैंने यार अपना
इनपुट एसटीडी यहां से लिया मैंने और यहां
पर भी स्टडी इन लिया उसके बाद ये है मेरा
एसटीडी आउट अगर इसकी कोई एरर होती तो क्या
होती वो अभी बाय डिफॉल्टर क्या है स्क्रीन
पर दिखाई देती है अगर उसको करना पड़ता है
तो आप सिंपली क्या करते हो तू के साथ
ग्रेटर दें सिंबल उसे करते हो क्योंकि
उसका भाई डिपॉजिट राहत है उसको क्या आया
है अगर आपको रीडायरेक्ट करना हो तो उसके
लिए आपको तू लगाना पड़ता है लेकिन जो जीरो
और वन होता है जो एसटीडी इन जीरो होता है
और एसटीडी आउट वन होता है वो बाय डिफॉल्टर
उन सिंबल के साथ राहत है वो आपको लगाने की
कभी जरूर नहीं पड़ती इसलिए मैंने बोला था
की फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन को मेरा कॉन्सेप्ट
पढ़ने के बाद एक बार दो बार उसको रिवाइज
कर लेना उसके बाद जो डेट थ्री की जो क्लास
हुई थी उसमें जो नितेश सर ने करवाया था
उसमें आप ठीक है फर्स्ट पार्ट आप स्किप
करो उसके अलावा जो उन्होंने बताया था जी
कमांड को एक्सप्लेन किया था की ये इनपुट
या आउटपुट डायरेक्शन उनको एक बार इस
कॉन्सेप्ट के साथ कल रेट करोगे तो मैं समझ
सकता हूं की सबसे बेस्ट कॉन्सेप्ट मैंने
बनाया है अब मैंने इसको डिलीवरी किया है
कभी भी आप स्क्रिप्टिंग में एवं किसी भी
कमांड को समझना में आपको प्रॉब्लम नहीं
होने वाली एसटीडी इन एसटीडी आउट और एसटीडी
पैनल के साथ मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं की
लोग बीटेक करते हैं बीटेक वाले लोग मैं जब
एक क्लास पढ़ा रहा था मेरी पहले इनर्स की
क्लास तो मैंने ये मैं अपने एक्सपीरियंस
आता हूं की ये फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन मैंने
उससे पूछा की यार आर यू वर्किंग इन बीटेक
आपको लास्ट फाइनल एयर में हो तो आपको
अच्छी खासी नॉलेज होगी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
वो बोलते की स्विफ्ट का मुझे कोई आइडिया
नहीं हमने कहानी पढ़ा ही नहीं की फाइन
होता गया तो ये वो चीज कुछ चीज होती हैं
की आप कहानी मिलती नहीं और लेकिन हम उसको
क्या रिसर्च करके आपके सामने डिस्कस किया
इसलिए आपको क्या है उसके साथ कंपेयर किया
है फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन के बड़े में नॉलेज
बहुत कम मिलेगी और जो मिलेगी कन्ज्यूरिंग
मिलेगी अगर इसके अंदर जितना अंदर जाओगे
दीप में उतना ही गहरा क्योंकि ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की बहुत ज्यादा दीप नॉलेज चाहिए
खास कर के ट्रैक्टर और उसके ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
के बड़े में कैसे कम करता है दोस्तों चीज
आप ज्यादा हॉट पाओगे की हां प्रोग्राम
कैसे अपलोड होता है कैसे होता है
बट अभी आपको इतनी ज्यादा जरूर नहीं है
लेकिन जो आपको जितना पता था बेसिक
कॉन्सेप्ट लेट करना है किसी भी कमांड के
साथ किसी स्क्रिप्टिंग लिखने वक्त तो ये
आपके लिए
नेक्स्ट आयोग की प्रिंस बताइए
[संगीत]
कुछ भी करोगे
है कुछ इनपुट देना है एवं आपको
इसके अंदर पैकेज इंस्टॉल करोगे अभी ये
साड़ी कमांड आपको आई है ना तो आपका क्या
की बहुत कम आसन हो जाएगा लाइनेक्स में
क्योंकि सर कम एथिकल हैकिंग का सर कम या
एवं आप शो के अंदर इसको कुछ भी हो सर का
सर कम क्या लाइनेक्स पे होता है तो ये मैं
ऐसा इस कैप्शन कोर्स में आपकी मैं एक ऐसी
डेवलपमेंट नॉलेज डेवलप्ड कर दूंगा उसके
बाद मैं आपको बताऊंगा की आप इसको कैसे उसे
कर सकते हो क्योंकि इसको उसे करना अभी मैं
बताता रहूंगा साथ क्या क्योंकि देखो मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं की अभी जो चल रहा है
आपका कॉन्सेप्ट चल रहा है की लास्ट लास्ट
क्लास है डिस्क्रिप्शन के बाद से जितने भी
कमांड होने वाली है ये टोटली इनका खेल
पूरा-पूरा है की आपको जो भी आउटपुट है
उसको कैसे ग्राफ करना है बेसिकली लाखों
लाइन की फाइल को
थ्रू कर सकते हो कैसे उसके अंदर आउटपुट
देख सकते हो अरे कमांड की अपनी इमिटेशन से
हरे कमांड का एक अपना वर्किंग कलर है उसको
उसे कर सकते हो ग्रह एसिड
हैं की जब आप
स्किपिंग कर रहे होंगे तो उसमें तो बहुत
ज्यादा हेल्पफुल होती है अब देखो की किसी
भी आउटपुट को आप इतनी आसानी से कट कर लोग
इतनी आसानी से बड़े-बड़े क्योंकि आपको अगर
किसी ने दिया की
लाइन 443 में ये 43 है इसमें मुझे ओनली
क्या चाहिए ये मुझे चाहिए इसके अंदर ये
फाइल नाम ओके और मुझे इसके अंदर क्या है
ये कीवर्ड चाहिए मुझे ओके उसके अलावा फिर
मुझे ये वाला लास्ट वाला चाहिए ये साड़ी
चीज अगर मुझे कट करके देनी है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा आइडिया नहीं होगा ना कैसे करोगे आप
इसको नो एडिटर के अंदर ओपन करोगे उसके बाद
उसको कट कॉपी पेस्ट करोगे इतना टाइम वेस्ट
करोगे किसी के पास इतना टाइम होता है क्या
लाइफ में नहीं होता तो इसके लिए साड़ी
कमांड होती है ये कम आपको सेकंड में हो
जाएगा
तो जैसे की आज मैंने क्या किया तो ऐसे ही
हम बीच-बीच में रखते रहेंगे और आप नोट
रखें नोट डॉ करके राखी है उसको हम क्लियर
करेंगे उसके बाद आपको ऑटोमेटिक जैसे की हम
नेक्स्ट जो कॉन्सेप्ट होंगे उनको जब हम
जैसे इनके साथ कर देंगे आपको अलग हो जाएगी
की हां मैंने उसे दिन वो चीज चाहिए थी
वहां से और उसे चीज के बाद यहां
इंप्लीमेंट कर रहा हूं वो ये तो वो चीज
ऐसी जोड़ेंगे डोंट वारी ये आपकी ये नॉलेज
बेस नहीं होने वाली इट्स मी बताइए
ओके तो फिर अभी किसी का कोई डाउट नहीं है
मुझे तो मैं समझ सकता हूं की जितने भी अभी
बाहर है लाइव में है तो उनके साथ स्टील
नोट आउट क्लियर है सब कुछ तो हम सेशन को
ओवर करते हैं
तो बाय बाय गुड नाइट